packed full of sumptuous homely dishes
today's all about comfort food i think
every home cook needs recipes that don't
just taste delicious but satisfy the
soul too the type of food that wraps its
arms around you and gives you big hugs
so when you want to give your family and
friends a big serving of love here's my
ultimate comfort food
dish is guaranteed to make you feel cozy
even on the coldest of days
first up a breakfast that will bring you
a warm glow in the morning my spiced
baked porridge
perfect for a big comfort family
breakfast
for lunch i'm pulling out all the stops
with a fantastic twist on one of
britain's favorite comfort dishes ginger
beer battered fish with chilli minted
mushy peas
if you're gonna do it
do it properly
for dinner my youngest daughter tilly is
in the kitchen and we share the secret
ingredient in every comfort food dish
happy memories
did you like to help me make your hot
pot when she made them for you
always such as hot pot with beetroot and
potato gratins on the menu for dessert
spiced apple compote
silly we're on for a treat this is my
ultimate comfort food breakfast
lunch and dinner
first up it's breakfast my spiced baked
porridge
absolutely love it why
i grew up with it there's something very
scottish about porridge
it's that kind of sort of great start to
the day
my father used to say
porridge needs salt
and salt only
it separates the men from the boys
didn't really like it it insisted salt
puts hairs on you
i used to sneak a couple of sugar lumps
from cafes and put them
in my porridge without him watching
these days my porridge has much more
flavor than just salt it's packed with
fruit nuts and spices add vanilla seeds
to porridge oats or oatmeal
really important just to rub the vanilla
through
the oatmeal makes it nice and fragrant
now a little teaspoon
of cinnamon makes it spicier and then
nutmeg
[Music]
already
that
smells incredible i quite like making
this up week at a time and
jack absolutely loves it now
whole almonds
now if you don't like that kind of
crunch running through the porridge you
can chop these up or blend them to a
powder but i quite like the sort of
texture hazelnut nuts incredibly good
a really nice crunch keep your vanilla
pod in there as well that just gives it
even more lift and of course once it's
baked just pull it out instead of sugar
i'm adding sweetness with fruit fresh
pears and raisins
cranberries are great as well chopped
apricots as well dried apricots in there
dried mango i love dried fruit
next pour in a pint of milk and mix
this can be done the night before left
in the fridge
and then
a couple minutes before you go to bake
it add your cream
now
into your dish
it looks quite liquid
but by the time it bakes
has this really nice rich crust on top
and then
just a nice little nutmeg
on top now bake at 180 for 30 to 35
minutes
then take the porridge out sprinkle on
demerara sugar and grill to create a
sweet golden crust
and sort of glaze on top
beautiful
literally
for three to four minutes
look at that
that makes me feel proud to be scottish
because it's perfect for a big comfort
family breakfast it's rich it's
sumptuous
and it's just a humble
oatmeal
phenomenal especially in the winter my
spice baked porridge with all those nuts
and fruit it's a bowl full of love to
start the day
[Music]
next i'm showing you how to cook the
comfort food i crave
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
make them
[Music]
my ultimate comfort food has to be
sausage i grew up on the classic british
banger made with ground pour salt pepper
spices and breadcrumbs and i'm using
these ones for dinner
the general rule with sausage the higher
the meat content the better they'll
taste
[Music]
for my ultimate lunch i'm frying fish so
you'll need an oil you can get to a high
temperature here are the different oils
you can use
groundnut oil it's made from peanuts and
it's used a lot in southeast asian
cooking
rapeseed made from those yellow
flowering crops this has the lowest
saturated fat content of any oil and has
a lovely delicate flavor
sunflower oil made from sunflower seeds
is mildly nutty
a good cheap all-rounder with a neutral
flavor is vegetable oil which is the
blend of oils like corn soybean and
sunflower
apples were my favorite fruit growing up
originally came from china but today in
britain we grow over 2 000 different
types
[Music]
the most popular eating apples in the uk
are braven and gala but don't miss out
on some of the older types like the
sweet nutty russets and fragrant coxes
when it comes to cooking apples it's got
to be a sharp brambly which i'm using as
part of my compot for lunch
you know that feeling when you really
want a particular dish and nothing else
will do that's comfort food ultimate
comforting lunch has to be fished with
peas i've loved it ever since i was a
kid and to make it even more delicious
i've given it a few modern tweaks for my
ultimate fish i'm doing the best
crunchiest lightest batter imaginable
with a hint of ginger
to go with it chilly minted mushy peas
[Music]
in order to make sure that the batter
stays nice and crispy and the fish stays
nice and firm
the secret is to season the fish salt
and pepper that will draw out the
moisture and that'll keep the fish
really nice and firm
put it in the fridge for around 10
minutes to let the seasoning work its
magic now the batter as always
when making any batter always sieve the
flour i want a bit of heat in the batter
so
a nice teaspoon of cayenne pepper
season the flour salt and pepper
and then
two teaspoons of baking powder
this almost lightens the load with the
batter now ginger beer
it gives that batter this sort of unique
spicy individual flavor it's delicious
with a fish and a nice tablespoon
of oil
just basic vegetable oil gives it a nice
sheen
give that a good mix
you really want it almost like the
consistency of
double cream
too thin and the batter runs off
especially when it hits the fryer too
thick and it actually prevents the fish
from getting cooked so you've got to get
it to that just that sort of double
cream texture let it rest for as long as
possible to give you an even textured
batter
now the season should have worked its
magic and drawn out the excess moisture
from the fish so it's on to the next
stage
fish
has gone slightly firmer
perfect for frying
start by coating the fish in flour
seasoned with pepper
pat that nice and dry into your hands so
you haven't got any excess flour the
flour stops the batter from running off
the fish i'm just gonna check to see if
my oil's ready by putting a little touch
of batter
into the fryer
you see it bubbling straight to the very
top
that tells you that the oil is ready
never really ever fill the pan
above halfway
if the oil starts to get too hot
first thing you do turn off the gas
second thing add some oil into it to
cool it down
hold the fish by the corner
unless you put it in
and roll it round
then gently slap the fish on the sides
of the bowl to get rid of excess batter
now
in
and lay away
and just gently drop it in
twist
your pan
that stops it from sticking
at the bottom
oil should be gently sort of bubbling
away
but notice as we're frying the fish
there's no
spitting of any water from the fish fry
the fish for three to five minutes
gently turning halfway through
once the batter is golden and crisp it's
ready
look they look stunning it's like these
big crispy pillows of
beautifully textured cart
leave the fish to rest on a kitchen
towel to blot excess oil
meanwhile it's quick and easy chilly
minted mushy peas
now how much you peas a little teaspoon
of olive oil
and a nice
knob of butter
into the pan
shallot
finely chopped that adds a bit of
sweetness to the peas slots into the pan
chili
these are delicious when you eat peas
and they're slightly spicy
they're even better
garlic
in the peas sweat off the chili the
garlic and the shallots
before the peas join those spices simply
blanch in salted boiling water infuse
with their perfect partner
fresh mint stalks and all
and then put your frozen peas in now
what's the peas i've got nice and soft
drain them now take off the stalks and
then add your peas to the shallots
i love that sound
mix all that chili and garlic
in there
a little seasoning
finishing the frozen peas off like this
absolutely delicious
onto your board
crush
now
you cannot beat
crushed
delicious peas
those peas is incredible
top with chopped mint
chilli minted mushy peas so simple and
perfect with easy ginger beer battered
fish
a nice spicy crispy batter and that just
reaffirms
the importance of comfort food if you're
gonna do it
do it properly
oh
my spicy twist is proof you can update a
comforting classic
and the best way to eat this is with
crispy buttered sauteed potatoes cooked
with garlic rosemary and thyme
to take this happy food to a whole new
level
[Music]
no question about it the best comfort
food is definitely homemade wonderful
smells filled in the kitchen delicious
freshly cooked food and a big side order
of nostalgia for me fantastic stews hot
pots and puddings will always hit the
mark and remind me of my mum that's why
i love them my ultimate comforting
dinner is a real favorite in our house
and i hope it will always remind my kids
of me
[Music]
and joining me in the kitchen to cook
the comfort food of my childhood is my
youngest daughter tilly
my ultimate comfort food dinner is a
stunning sausage hot pot which will
serve with a gorgeous potato and
beetroot gratin
now i love hot pot you love hot pot
and you love sausages right yeah what do
you enjoy most about sausages
um i just love having them
with the baked beans sometimes with
baked beans sometimes these are
little button mushrooms okay you just
take them into there like that
and keep them whole and cut them into
quarters please
now the important thing about cooking
sausages is they need a bit of color
right no color no flavor exactly get the
pan
nice and hot
how was school today school was good
thanks we got to go out and make snowmen
sausages in
okay butter mushrooms in there please my
daddy
[Music]
see
now
i want you to wash your fingers but you
know how to slice onions right
definitely i'll be your day now
sausages
are getting lots of color because this
is going to cook slowly
and it's sort of daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one
nannies to make for me yeah once you've
got the color on them
and take them out
to rest okay
a little normal butter okay into the pan
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so that will go down by half
give that a little fry
okay
salt in
i want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little buds
that will get the onions
packed with flavour mmm that's not nice
nice mushrooms in give them a nice
little stir
did you like to help them make your hot
pot when she made them for you i used to
always help them make the hot pot
always
now my mum would never have used this
but a's balsamic vinegar brings out the
flavour of the onions right now look at
our onions
look beautifully caramelized
the vinegar has given that nice sort of
gloss i'm going to put my sausages back
in here now from there
some red wine
red wine in
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is going to release all that flavor
inside as well look at the color of that
does that look pretty good
and it's still not cooked yet up to the
ball really important to boil it here
because it won't boil in the oven 170
in the oven literally
18 to 20 minutes then she goes
nice
to go with my hot pot rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and i'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
start by gently heating double cream
[Music]
then peel and thinly slice potatoes and
cook beetroot
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and
seasoning
beetroot
between
[Music]
end with a neat layer of potatoes
and pour the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beetroot gratin a bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the apple compote what we need
to do first is to get these peeled
and sliced
i get my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
they're incredibly acidic
okay and you need to cook them those
wonderful red apples you've got are
called brae burns what other apples you
know green ones what are they called um
i'm not too sure what the green one is
another word for your nan
grandmas no
red no pink lady apple no
granny smith
granny smith apples that's right
what we're gonna do
is cook the cooking apples
and
the eating apples together
i love the combination of the tartness
from the brambly cooking apple with the
sweetness of the brae bun get the pan
nice and hot
and sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger and three little cinnamon sticks
i want you to remember that because
we're gonna look for them
okay because once we've used them
and they've worked their magic i need to
pull them out see all the sugar
dissolving
definitely now we just let that go a
little bit darker
okay
and then the place is quick
doesn't it
give that
a nice
little
toss
okay
nice golden color cinnamon in ginger in
so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cook until the apples soften then
take off the heat
they go into there what's that coming
out dad so that is a little bit of the
puree i'll show we'll do that in a
minute how many ginger
four four ginger
and three cinnamon three cinnamon out
with the cinnamon
we've got another ginger gingers
smells so nice how nice is that look see
the colory apples
let's put these in the fridge to get
nice and cold
that's the compost sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to crown the top
do you separate the egg whites into
there for daddy
all right egg whites are in they're
great separate
off
[Music]
and i'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
[Applause]
good girl
[Music]
now let's see if you've got a really
nice stiff peak so you lift them up
and that is what i call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad
next in a separate bowl whip double
cream until stiff
nice and slowly
so cream whips so much quicker
yeah
nice that by hand
we're gonna
put some delicious lemon zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compot puree
you mix that in nice and carefully
so it's like this apple
butterscotch
now to make the cream even lighter fold
in those whisked egg whites and sugar
egg whites
into the cream
just
nicely fold that in
so you bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses yep
good girl
silly we're on for a treat
open up the piping bag
now twist the end
now you could spoon this in but i want
to just give a nice little lift it also
gives it a nice pattern
lemon on top
back in the fridge
the beetroot and potato gratin
that lovely that's lovely
sausages
finished with a flat leaf parsley
wow look at those two beauties
it doesn't get any more comforting than
that does it for one of the best hot
pots
ever tilly that looks amazing
i know well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by apple compote
food with guaranteed feel good factor
mommy jack holly megan
doesn't it
[Music]
it smells amazing
tasty delicious one of my favorite it's
so tasty i love it it's so good i love
the mushrooms as well that is so nice
and so simple when i was your age guys
nanny was making this for me
in those days the sausages weren't as
fat as those days you would ride to
school on dinosaurs
excuse me i'm not out
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
you